[Musique]
bon mes chéris
très content de cette première journée
j'avais été exceptionnel là j'ai dit
fier de vous régaler un petit peu à voir
on va aller dans un cabaret chez un ami
vous allez kiffer très beau spectacle
on va manger bon je mange plus tu
gonfles on te voit quoi y aller on va
aller chez mon ami il ya juste un petit
souci à quoi vous allez devoir peut-être
des paniers mon ami je vous expliquerai
voyez vous pas tout vous dire ok ok
c'est fou on y va
[Musique]
les basques poursuit cyril on est sûrs
d'aller vers le succès
ça
[Musique]
bonjour
merci cher
c'est gentil papa c'est sympa mais si on
peut rentrer la clé regardez secte et
ouais c'est pas parce que les déchirer
je vais ouvrir et derrière il va se
passer quelque chose d'exceptionnel
voilà des mille et une nuits dalmatiens
alice au pays des merveilles avec mozart
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup
ouah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
probablement
me voir dans mon avis on va vers contre
toujours sauf que j'ai à petit problème
moi j'ai un d'humour le chanteur a une
danseuse mois sont pas les séries
l'année à bas coûts wizz tradition avec
un motard c'est laurel et hardy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est tout mais tous les endroits qui
croise le regard
la sulfureuse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vim
moi
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
choix
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bon bah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour prendre le sucre bilan précis
j fréquence et marty pour ge et requiert
dix mois qui m'a dégoté hydra dans les
hauteurs de la souris
là
cya
[Musique]
m
je suis
non la ville de
moi je suis d'ici
oui
[Musique]
pour être alerté
[Applaudissements]